Hi.
This is Brian.
Let's see how quickly
we can start up
a cluster of machines on
Google Compute Engine.
So this here is
the Cloud Console.
We're opened up into the
Compute Engine tab VM Instances.
And let's go ahead and
just start a new machine.
Click New Instance.
We fill out some data.
The main thing we need to
change the defaults for
is specify a name.
Make sure we pick a zone that
is close to you for good round
trip times.
Then we boot from an image.
We're going to do
[? WN ?] in this case.
And we just go ahead
and click Create.
So this has now started
the creation process.
This web UI makes calls out
to the Compute Engine API,
which is an HTTP REST API, and
prepares everything and gets us
a machine running.
And in fact, it's already up and
running before I've even hardly
had a chance to talk about it.
So here's our new instance.
What was the IP address?
And we could just click
SSH and start using it.
But part of the promise
of Cloud is scalability.
So let's see how quickly
we could scale up
a whole cluster of instances.
So this is a demo app
that calls the same API.
Let's go ahead and set up a
smallish cluster of machines.
And when I click
Start there, it calls
those same API's and allocates
and prepares 100 disks,
each with a copy
of the same image.
As the squares
start turning blue,
those squares represent
machines that have actually
completed that process
of preparing the disks.
And there we go.
And then once they
start turning green,
that's a computer that
is up and ready for work.
As soon as it's
finished booting,
it can run a script
that you specify.
You can run anything
you want here,
set up configuration
management, install dependencies
for your application, whatever
preparation you need to do.
Perhaps check out code
and get that installed.
And then you can
run your software.
And here we go, a
cluster of 100 machines
ready to run your
software in 40 seconds.
Thank you very much.
And happy hacking
with Compute Engine.